[Music]
in pranked the prank news prank the
prank I like it how do you play the
break submitted by white fudge Oreos
exist that exists is that the golden
ones no no no oh if it's white fudge I
need to see this a man jokingly
auctioned off his used girlfriend on
eBay and got his huge office what's it
usable because she's not a virgin
anymore
maybe she's vintage she's old yeah cuz
classical cars get they get they
appreciate women do not appreciate
though we depreciate like a so Chong
women some women are putting myself in
that category
one of those shading as we see no really
no I will not put myself in that
category I'm sorry you get old you get
wiser [ __ ] ya learn better sex for [ __ ]
yeah Thank You Tiffany but you also get
crow's feet so what you already have
them yeah but when guys get crow's feet
we look more like George Clooney's more
distinguished it's all about the
confidence alright confidence makes you
beautiful we look more and more small
got that wrist pop and they don't stop
look at my [ __ ] posture went like it
was like this and I went it's about the
fully confident of God oh wow
that's what it is yeah all the girls are
way better they can suck things so much
better than those [ __ ] young girls
especially when they take off their
dentures take em off
let them yeah be bench that huh no you
suck yo dick so this dude David Dale
he's 34 years old he put his girlfriend
named Kelly who's 37 years old on eBay
this is a couple Dale Dale and Kelly
they're from the UK she looks used
do the women empowerment though she does
compared to him hold us here 34 37 holy
[ __ ] he's 34 no thank you
I'm 34 please 34 but he looks like he
could be my dad you know what this is
though this is like two people that
thought that they could ten and just
obliterated
they just drank a little you that fool
look like a man man though he looks like
you [ __ ] cuts trees for a living
we're not mean we're observant
he looks yeah he looks like he's a
lumberjack for for a trade yeah you find
a Tiffany you just don't want to say it
he is the largest thank you much older
than she does that's Aloha say yeah the
audacity right by the way they're
they're good-looking people it's just
that their age surprised me maybe we
just think we look hella young but we
don't I don't write everyone in the
comments like [ __ ] you guys just like in
you old [ __ ] no cuz that was like me
when I was really fat I was sick and I
would judge other fat people and look at
them eat and then marry well it could be
like no people there surprised by my age
cuz I don't meet me right oh sure a big
fat been watching since I was in junior
high about to graduate college now under
like wait how old are you oh my oh [ __ ]
that's true if I've been the part of the
life for like ten years
yeah those are rough yeah I am
officially 26 years old like they're 12
and then we'll end up 22 now yeah I
don't care if I'm all I just want to
stay funny I don't care if I'm old if
I'm rich but I don't have that right now
so I care I don't care if I'm Paul
either we were waiting for the extra
thing no but I did that for fun I don't
I don't mind if I'm old if I feel young
and I'm new and I move young you know
what I mean well that's what yeah like
well you know how a lot of people that
complaining like the foot bones don't
feel good or like
can the mcil lose the weight whatever
I'm as long as I can still feel
aesthetic and I'm still making
improvements that's fine with me
I'm old enriched I'm okay if I'm old and
poor something went wrong wrong that
little little little road path to life
or something you know me call me
goalkeeper young yeah yeah so this dude
he was selling his girlfriend as a joke
because she whipped him across his butt
in a writing shop and so he was like an
act of revenge because I guess they play
around a lot like that that's dope
that's cute
that's a cute relation that is cute
super cute so then they're saying that
within 12 hours the couple had about
$50,000 yeah that's amazing yeah the
people if it's like a creepy guy I want
to like have sex with his wife and like
wear her skin that's why it's like
pranked the prank because all these
people that are participating on eBay
they were also like pranking back they
were just like oh how much well for
summer this is the posting the girl or
she looks different they're like way
different yeah what the [ __ ] yeah age
maybe that was just a bad photo on she's
like clear on ebay if you put up a bid
right and no one outbid you didn't you
have to pay them if they accept it if
the sellers oh okay yeah so then like it
says here it says seller assumes all
responsibilities listing for four parts
or not working an item that does not
function as important doesn't work yeah
so this is girlfriend for sale starts
okay but after a while there's a
constant whining noise and I can't seem
body work is fairly tidy but close-up
shows signs of where parentheses and was
describing me right now no serious
damage but you can see that she's been
used please bear in mind when she's
bidding she's 37 years old basically
first thing in the morning she can be
very temperamental once warmed up once
warmed up the whining noise lessons but
I would be lying if I said it goes away
completely the rear end leaks a bit but
nothing that can't be plugged no tire
kickers any offers considered would be
interested
and a part would be interested in a part
exchange with a younger model sold at
sea no return that's responding like how
many owners does she has that's pretty
awesome
is it well-worn or still of you with
minimal signs of use and I see there's
only one pic are you hiding anything
does she smoke when she's being revved
hard oh my god yeah
she's a pretty down ass girl yeah I mean
to me to allow this to happen cuz I know
if I did this to Muriel I would have a
knife in my stomach
100% I like this I like this couple I
think they have so much fun yeah they're
cute yeah
so then eBay they ended up taking the
post down after 24 hours and the bid
reached her 119 thousand Oh what damn
she's a solder Duda I'm down let's do it
I'm ready I already have listing oh it's
party up right now been up for like ten
years by the way outfitting myself still
our bomb thank you
I've been out betting myself every week
how cute is even cuter that's busy you
want a good once to have a good day
finally at $76 great day
yes so then that's when Dell said that
Kelly asked him so what price would you
actually have sold me for and then she's
gonna have a good day or a bad day let's
hear it no but then she is up saying
would you have been upset if someone
actually bought me and then he said I
would have been upset but I would have
been crying in either a Lamborghini or a
Ferrari which makes it a whole lot
better he's a realist yeah so they've
been friends for 10 years but they've
been only dating a year and so they're
saying that that's a funny prank no see
that's why it's because they developed
that 10-year friend
friendship thing that's why he get away
with that cuz I don't know what many
girls that would do that especially when
you're 37 about to hit 40 I think that's
the time when a lot of people start to
feel weird about their age and then you
say stuff about oh when you look a
little closer a little bit worn out even
if it's a joke it's kind of like oh [ __ ]
that's funny did you
yes they can insecurities yeah a little
bit you know so I'm saying like I'm kind
of surprised she was cool with that I
think a lot of girls would be okay with
it but you're nothin well sporty yet so
you wouldn't know like mm-hmm
girls always say that I don't want to
hear that [ __ ] from girls because it's
always the same I'm okay what you know
it's cuz you're the girl that's like I
know but I'm saying though Real Talk
though when time comes every girl says
that thing every girl says they have a
sense of human touch to our clan them
and then they exactly cuz it was funny
when you guys were in the beginning and
it was fun but after you get personal
things starts to feel a little more
closed your guards down a little bit so
what's Italy know what it is it's just
not a balance
cuz some guys just don't know how to
compliment the right way and then they
think everything's a joke so they joke
about it too much I think you should be
looking at him where you say this game
would be better okay I [ __ ] up
something yeah no but I think it's cuz
girls when they say that too it's
because they expect the level of
clowning that they do amongst their
friends but guy level cloudy it's very
different and there's no balance so
there's not enough to support and bring
it back up and yeah that's what cuz you
always want to feel like the Queen yeah
but by us but by us clowning the [ __ ]
out of you is us showing love and bring
you up low you guys just don't know how
that cuz I've never changed I stayed the
exact same yeah I come the exact same
amount but suddenly like something like
Joe and Jess right just kept calling Joe
a fat [ __ ] for like ever and then that
got to him and then he like I've stayed
the same in clown just as hard and he's
gotten more sensitive yeah you see so it
happens both ways that's because when
they were together he had a six-pack it
was a difference gnorga bait and switch
mine was different I promised Mariel I
was gonna lose weight in the first year
we're together took four years finally
got it Hey oh it's way better for her I
think I think what it is is if you guys
aren't in a good place and they're
cookin you're doing the clowny oh yeah
cuz that's that's that's us it's like a
stroke it's like I already hate you
right now
and I'm about though I'm about to throw
you out of this balcony and you want to
[ __ ] around and it's like then I get it
and it's like oh you know what it's not
a gendered thing it's like you got a
have you been on have you guys been
close lately have you been cool lately
and then what does that close this mean
is an emotional thing but the point is
it's like the joke is only okay if you
guys are cool mmm but if you can it
always live on like the joke should
always come out and should always live
no matter how you feel cuz it can help
the emotions
no no because you're joking to is coming
out no no because here's the thing
here's the thing here's the thing
there's a difference between playfulness
and intent to hurt yeah that's the
difference of how guys and girls I think
plays I feel like we play but then we're
not trying to get back and hurt anybody
that's true this one on the other hand
that's why it's like make the funniest
thing come out of my mouth and sometimes
it's really harsh well here's a pig but
it's supposed to be fun but if we're
already arguing and if we're not on the
song if we're not cool and you say that
to hurt my feelings it's not a joke
anymore I don't ever go like when
they're arguing and I'll never go like
get you fat [ __ ] like I don't
guys always have intended come out maybe
they tell ya exactly it's a delivery
right come out like 1% spite that see
that's triggered by a fight yeah 24
hours that way yeah yeah yeah no but
most that's I think that's where we draw
the line right is like one is just pure
fun and games and then the other one has
added baggage and resentment and hate
and spite and then you feel that [ __ ]
that's why there's been times where we
can [ __ ] around all day and there's no
added spite so I'm just like yeah call
me fat I don't care it's funny but when
there's the added hate then I could feel
that I'm like that [ __ ] was not for fun
that [ __ ] was to punch me yeah yeah yeah
ways that we joke to and what we joke
about right so when I make fun of
somebody I never talk about stuff that's
actual real like I'll come up and I'll
say you [ __ ] ugly [ __ ] she's not
ugly clearly she's not ugly
you guys hear that David finally Joe
ugly ass up dude you know it's like one
of those type of things yeah and it's
very different from things that are
actually some people are instrument that
don't make that example for example like
if you were dealing with weight issues
at the moment and then that's something
that you're kind of insecure about and
in people are really on you all the time
about that that's a little bit different
from how you putting the whole ear thing
huh but that's not it issue you said you
were over it already yeah yeah yeah
bringing down all your things we helps
you well you're by the way you did
things just stupid there's a big long
fingers what's absolutely never talking
about a medical condition and someone
trying to get over a hub versus like a
normal half year a little bit smaller
than the other finger bump theme that
you play them on Isaac your [ __ ]
nasal dripping all those things are so
stupid dark circles all those things are
things that don't even [ __ ] matter
that's hot
yeah but do we clown on you for family
problems or things that you're really
bothered by you see that's very
different men and women for a
conversation she's still upset he's
still talking about me you know every
time we do one of these videos I get in
trouble with Mary OH later on ficus you
watch it there before it gets crazy you
let's save my relationship thank you we
appreciate you guys for watching this so
much we love you guys this is real [ __ ]
[Laughter]
my lips got chapped [ __ ] getting
angry math bugs
[Music]